a correspondent for fox news bill
mulligan
published a video on monday that helps
put things into perspective
this is what life is like for police
officers these days the video is footage
from a body camera
worn by a los angeles county sheriff's
deputy interestingly enough
the department doesn't require its
officers to wear body cameras this
officer
chose to wear one for his own protection
and it's very good
that he made that choice because
recently a woman called internal affairs
to file a harassment complaint against
him she claimed
that he harassed her during a traffic
stop unfortunately the deputy had his
camera rolling during that stop
and it becomes very clear very quickly
just who is doing the harassing during
this interaction
the woman is so far unnamed and as soon
as she is named i'll be sure to tell
you her name and plaster it everywhere
that i can now i'm not always a fan of
public shaming but some people richly
deserve it and oh
does this woman deserve it uh
so let's uh let's play this let's listen
to this
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40
and i was going 38 so why are you
harassing you are correct i pulled you
over
because you're a murderer yes i started
to record because you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving i was recording you
because you said you can't you can't use
your cell phone while you're recording
you
may i have your driver's license i it's
it's at my
apartment what's your apartment it's at
my home i'm just taking my son to his do
you have
do you have your driver's license i it i
mistakenly left it at home do you have a
picture of your driver's license yes i
do
may have it and can you call your
supervisor
please because i already did he's on his
way because you're a murderer
okay and so you're giving me a cell
phone ticket
is that why you're harassing me it's not
harassment i i am enforcing the laws i
have a right to
and record the police when they're
harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i would i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that do you
have
that picture of me and made me think you
were gonna murder me okay well i'm sorry
you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer okay
can you zoom in on that for me yeah
thank you and i'm
perfectly legal and i'm a teacher
so there congratulations of course she
is
of course she's a teacher oh you knew
that you just from this
from everything her behavior the sound
of her voice
you already knew she was a teacher
melligan says that she
has worked as a professor at colleges in
the area apparently this is just another
reason why her name and faith should be
published
the public has the right to know where
this psycho is teaching
besides she was filming the encounter
too so she obviously wants it to be made
public
i mean we should respect her wishes and
make it as public as possible she wants
to be famous so
i say let's oblige there's plenty more
to say about this and a couple of larger
points i want to make but first let's uh
let's watch
the rest of the footage because it does
gets worse it does get worse if you can
believe it
you're a murderer what's your last name
i can't see that there well
stop shaking zoom in on that floor no
because you're scaring me
they're threatening to kill me and my
son can you give me okay
you i'll tell you what you keep smiling
you're on camera
you're trying to threaten to kill me i'm
smiling you're the one who's
hold that still i can't see that is this
your car yes it is
and you're trying to say i stole my own
car because you're jealous
yeah i don't think so you away from me
right here okay you're jealous
all you need to do is your signature
he's only citing you for using your cell
phone while you're driving that's it
there you go bam sign inside the rifle
for him being a mexican racist what is
that name
it's under citation man here you go
mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that
right
you'll never be white which is what you
really want to be there you go dear
right
have a good day
what a lovely what a lovely woman a
little racism there at the end why not
why not throw that in there for good
measure
you've already decided to be a scumbag
scumbag might as well go full hog i
guess
and yet after all that the vile
disgusting witch of a woman gets only a
citation
for using a cell phone while driving the
officer actually cuts her a break
doesn't get her for driving without a
license needless to say
this is a man with with with near super
human patients
if that were me i would have given her
every ticket i could have possibly
justified and then a few more that i
can't
i also probably would have been
screaming at her to shut her stupid
mouth
because you know i'm on the opposite end
of the patient spectrum i have to admit
this is the kind of patience that police
officers must
so often demonstrate they deal with
people like this
all the time in fact that was easy
compared to how so many other traffic
stops have gone
especially in la at least she didn't
physically assault the officer or try to
shoot him so that's progress
practices can lend a little bit of
perspective some police officers
are bad just like some members of every
profession are bad in some professions
the percentage of bad
is much higher than others professions
like academia for example
riddled with lunatics like this for
police officers only some are bad
some like this deputy are almost
unbelievably good at their jobs everyone
else falls in between
they're just normal people doing their
best bad days and good days successes
and failures
getting by as well they can i mean this
describes
the vast majority of people on earth in
all vocations and all occupations
now what happens when a normal person
is subjected to constant harassment and
taunting
what happens when they're forced to
encounter the absolute dregs of humanity
day in and day out what happens when
they spend all day
every day dealing with drug addicts
domestic abusers gang bangers drunks
people of that sort it has a
psychological effect
so my point is that whenever we see body
cam footage of some
citizen acting like a lunatic around the
police
we're always asked to see things from
that person's perspective to understand
the pain and trauma that led to that
behavior and so on
well what about the pain and trauma of
the guy wearing the camera
might we consider things from his
perspective too sometimes
i know that if i had to deal with people
like that woman every day
and worse it wouldn't take long to turn
me into a jaded aggressive jerk
in fact i already am a jaded aggressive
jerk and i only work in media
so the majority of police critics
if they had to deal with stuff like that
all the time
they'd be far worse than the worst
police officer that they criticize
two other things to think about first we
don't talk enough about the entitlement
problem
and how it intersects with these issues
this woman has a sense of entitlement so
pronounced that it's driven her
into basically madness
she's furious that the officer would
dare pull her over to enforce the law
she feels that she's entitled to do
whatever she wants
whenever she wants and anybody who danes
to prevent her is to her mind
effectively a murderer
she's so entitled that even when the
officer cuts her a massive break
she still isn't satisfied to have even
been inconvenienced
is an affront that she cannot bear now
she might be a somewhat extreme case but
this kind of entitlement to one degree
or another
is extraordinarily common it's another
thing that cops run into
every single day just consider the fact
that in a great many of the police body
cam videos or witness cell phone videos
we've seen
the perp who was allegedly the victim of
police brutality was committing a crime
and then resisted arrest when the police
came to enforce the law
they act shocked and angered by the fact
that the law is being applied
to them they're so self-entitled that
they expect they can
refuse to be arrested and the cop will
just go well okay never mind sir
sorry to have sorry to have bothered you
in this fine afternoon
when the cop doesn't respond that way
they become violent
again police encounter this mentality
day in and day out
also the woman in that video let's focus
on this for a second
she repeatedly claims that she is scared
another thing we hear all the time all
these people who say they're scared to
death afraid they'll be murdered by the
cops blah blah etc
but so often these scared people act
exactly like this woman
she's scared of the cop and yet she's
going out of her way to antagonize him
she's yelling at him insulting him
trying to
instigate a reaction she's already
gotten a break
they're about to let her leave and she's
still screaming at him
and insulting him she's afraid that
he'll kill her and yet she taunts him
relentlessly
is that how scared people behave have
you ever been so scared of someone
that you walk up to them and say hey you
big fat
dummy kiss my ass if you're acting that
way to someone should we assume that
you're
scared of that person
we're even expected to believe that the
people who resist arrest
who actually initiate violent encounters
with police
who choose of their own volition to
create
a violent situation with police
they're scared too we're supposed to
believe
they're committing a crime they're being
arrested for committing a crime
all that is totally fair they could
simply
go off to to to to to jail
fight this in the courts but then
they decide to make it violent didn't
have to be they made it that way
because they're scared huh
and the blm rioters in the street who
throw rocks at cops taunt them cuss them
out
sometimes strip off their clothes and
dance naked in front of them
they're scared too supposedly all of
these people professing to be deathly
afraid of the police and yet acting
towards the police
in exactly the sort of way you'd act
towards someone if you weren't afraid of
them
in the slightest could it be that all
this talk about being scared as nonsense
could it be that it's nothing but
emotional blackmail
an act a charade to justify their own
despicable and indefensible behavior
yes it could be and it is in fact nearly
everything you hear from the anti-cop
left is bogus
everything the claims they make about
policing in general are statistically
false
but even the claims they make about
their own emotional states
are also false it is all false
all a lie every bit of it
and we should never forget that well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content